And to live...
...Catholic Majesty Isabella, King Ferdinand of Spain,
inhabitants of the town of Palos are ordered...
Oh, let's go!
...to provide and fit out two ships within ten days.
They will be prepared and put at the disposal of Senor Columbus, who is here present.
We would pre-size within a delay of ten days.
Look at my boat. She needs repairs. They'll take three months.
Why not come back when she's seaworthy?
Requisition my boat? Oh, no, Senor, you may not.
No, my boat happened to be in England. I'm sorry, Senor, you're out of luck.
The Majesties, we requisition your ships now.
You want to requisition my ships, Signor? Go on, take them. I'm only too delighted.
No doubt about it. Enormous riches to explore. Wealth beyond dream.
And how many souls to convert to our holy church.
What do you think, Martin Pinzon?
Signor Columbus, do you really believe it possible the lands of the East, Congo, could be so close to the lands of the West?
I shall speak of it with my brother Vincente. I believe he will agree.
Which an adventure is indeed tempting.
See, the Nina and the Pinta are small ships, but sturdy.
They will hold to the course. So be it.
I will command the Pinta and my brother, the Nina.
We all agree?
Yeah, agree.
Sounds good.
And we have managed to convince our Basque to give us a ship for the voyage.
It's called the Marigallot, for our crews.
Where will we get them?
There are plenty of idle sailors around, the Desacupados.
Yes, but the men know how many deaths there have been on these voyages.
No, even gallowsbirds run the other way when we try to recruit them.
It's that that makes the enterprise difficult.
You'll need to panic, lads.
I'll bring them around for you.
See, pangos, where you'll be headed, everybody knows that the roofs are made of gold.
You'll all get richer than you have ever dreamed.
Each man will have a daily ration of a pound of biscuits, plenty of meat, and fish.
Oil and vinegar, cheese, vegetables, lots of them, onions, real onions, and much more, you hear me?
And good wine, two bottles, daily. Lord forgive me.
Yes, you heard right, two bottles of wine every day, and you will get a bonus in advance.
That's an offer I can't refuse. I'm going.
Thank you so much.
They don't look as if they'd cause any harm.
They're Jews.
Versos, it's the will of the Holy Inquisition.
Excellency, King's notary.
Excellency, the King's steward.
Your Excellency, Supervisor of Equipment.
Welcome, the God of all provisions.
Welcome, King's interpreter.
Interpreter?
Sure, he's supposed to speak Greek, Hebrew, Arabic, and all the rest.
He's polyglot.
His name hoist up the sails.
All hands and God's name hoist the sails.
In the name of God, hoist sails.
You surely saw the ship drift.
Seeing his majesty's orders, I shall have to place you under arrest.
You will follow us.
Do you really think we'll allow you to get away with this?
Another question.
Maybe now you ought to arrest.
Was there an emergency where we let it go?
You've been eating.
You managed to seal some grub while we were all sleeping.
Only you must be starved.
Now listen, we'll see that you're all right and we'll give you eat.
I'll tell a few of the lads that we can trust not to worry.
You can even come up on deck for a breath of fresh air.
But look out that the admiral doesn't see you.
He's in a foul mood these days.
Still no lands come in sight.
The men are becoming restless, difficult to handle.
London's sign, my friends.
It means lands very near.
Think to your calculations, Admiral.
In my opinion, we had better change course.
Sail more to the west-southwest.
Land should be there.
Why do that?
Well, observe the flight of the birds.
We must let them guide us out.
So, we're agreeing.
Columbus failed to discover America and the Florida coast,
but only a small island in the Bahamas.
Why did Columbus do that?
Why? Tell us, Maestro.
No, you have to see it from his point of view.
For two months, they had been sailing.
By now, they didn't know where they were.
No landmarks, no sign.
Any welcome change was...
And I'd say he's got serious problems with the crew.
Oh, yes, to say the least.
With this poor excuse for an admiral.
Yeah, you're right. He doesn't even know where he's going.
He's got us into a real mess, he has.
Not one among us will make it home again.
Come on, string him up.
No, a pair of lead boots and lower it into the water.
But then what?
All that bunch on the Neen on the Pinta, they're a rough lot.
Yeah, the ones on the pinta especially.
Friends, I thank you all.
You have all shown great patience.
We can't be far from land now.
It's a matter of hours, and the first to sight land will receive 10,000 maravides from our gracious queen.
Near Colombia, you will not fight Juan Rodriguez.
What reward?
The first man to sight land would receive 10,000.
That was the first to slow coming from land.
Ask these gentle islands around Cipango.
Possession of the pre-named Holy Saviour San Salvador.
Cipango is the city with roofs of gold.
"Coste usted, Cipango, la ciudad de oro."
"Oye, what are you?"
"Baca, parato, bula, pagoteca."
"The man says if we go south, we locate."
"And the gold? Where do we find it?"
"Parato, amongo, atopolo, baragogo."
"We go south."
"This man says in the south a powerful king possesses vases of gold."
"Look here, my man. Ask all of them."
"Hoyol, hodemo, yohol, homogo, homongo."
After exploring the Bahamas, Columbus sailed for what he thought was Cipango.
It was really Cuba.
There he is to encounter a strange thing, natives smoking a sort of dried leaf.
And that was to be one of the discoveries that he brought back from America.
Hardly one of the best ones, I assure you, but then there we are.
Land, Hispaniola.
In fact, it was Haiti or Santo Bingo.
All these Indians don't look very Asian.
To see, 1492, while the crew was having a fine time, the Santa Maria somehow ran aground on a coral reef.
And so they'll have to abandon the ship there.
And since there isn't enough room for everybody in the two remaining ships, well, they found a colony, Villa de Navidad.
You will have an easy life.
The people are gentle.
Don't be brutal with them.
Collect some gold, well, let's say a barrel, and spices.
When we return with reinforcements, we will resume conquest.
Admiral, don't you worry.
I'll take personal charge.
14th of March, 1493, 224 days after his departure, Christopher Columbus returned to Palos, and he had discovered an immense continent.
He brought back no gold, but rather, he brought back maize, corn, maniak, tobacco, and Indians.
Ah, those Indians have asked me to transmit to you of your science you have shown,
which appears beyond the reach of mere mortal.
There are no man, Spain, who could have accomplished this.
Gentlemen, would any of you be able to make this egg that I hold stand up on end?
One can do anything once it's performed by another.
And what's your reply to that?
Months later, in September, 1493, a full fleet leaves Cadiz commanded by Columbus,
17 caravels and 1,200 men, including farmers, representatives of the various trades,
20 horsemen, sheep, seeds and tools, two brothers and six monks, including Bernard Boyle.
Oh, yes, and there he is, our friend, Piero. He's on the ship's crew this time.
Well, he's the cabin boy.
Spaniola, city of Navidad.
The supervisor and his men were a little too greedy and too grabby.
Only the gentle natives had had enough of it.
Right here, we will name it Isabella.
Since no more natives will help us, we will work with our bare hands.
We work with our bare hands. I would rather go to Spain, Admiral.
I shall go on board at once.
Dear friends, these lands belong to you.
As for me, I must return to inform their majesties what has happened.
But I shall return as soon as I can.
While I'm gone, brothers Diego and Bartolomeo will look after you all.
Of penance, Columbus is at last able to set off on his third voyage.
He takes with him 300 volunteers, 30 of them women, to provide good stock.
And this time, he skirts Venezuela and goes on to Hispaniola.
I can hardly wait to see Isabella.
After all this time, surely it has become a thriving community, a real colony.
Diego.
What joy.
Brother.
Tolomeo.
In the name of God, what's happened?
They refuse to obey us.
Obey anyone from Genoa, never.
We haven't any authority over them at all.
We can do nothing.
And they treat the Indians cruelly, steal their jewels.
And run after their women.
It's been sickness.
But what can I report to their majesties?
I'm in a very difficult position now.
Easy, but you have ships.
Why not take them as slaves?
The admiral who tries to play explorer.
Majesty, just what are we to do with these poor people?
What are your orders?
You will liberate them all, miserable souls.
Return them to their home, Hispaniola, at once.
Francisco Bodabia to the palace.
Appoint you governor of Hispaniola to replace Viceroy Columbus.
You will discover what the situation is there and dispatch a report to me directly.
Do you understand?
Now off you go.
The 24th of August, 1500, Bodabia arrived in Hispaniola.
His first act was to send Diego and Bartolomeo to prison.
And Columbus, where's Christopher Columbus?
Governor, we have arrested him.
Is he in irons?
Nobody here would dare do such a thing to him, Governor.
I'll do it. I swear I'll enjoy it.
Let me take your chains off. They're painful.
No, I'd rather wear them.
You would?
Truly, thank you. This way is better.
Poor Columbus. As a result, he disembarked a caddy's wearing chains.
Unfortunately, he was released on the orders of the Queen.
As Isabella received him with apologies, Budabia had overstepped his orders,
but there was no way for our friend to regain his title of viceroy, a governor.
He returned and retired to a Franciscan monastery and began a period of penance.
Well, I suppose that was about all the expeditions.
No, in 152, he was to leave again on his fourth, his last voyage.
It would prove to be the most painful of all.
Hurricanes and sickness, betrayals, famine, mutinies.
Yes, yes, he was spared no ordeal.
There isn't a hair on my body that hasn't turned white.
My body's exhausted, I can't go on.
How I long to see the dear land of Spain again.
How much I need sleep.
Two years after his return, Queen Isabella died two more years, and Columbus died too.
He was almost blind.
He paralyzed, miserable, and abandoned by everybody.
Well, nearly everybody.
See more than those islands, my children.
Cipango was in our grass, we nearly discovered it.
Yes, if we'd only...
Hardly a very pleasant ending for an explorer, wouldn't you say?
But do you realize it was the willpower and the perseverance of Columbus that truly opened the American continent to the world?